لم تجمعهم طاوله المفاوضات فجمعتهم
مناقشات مجلس الامن فتحدث الرئيس
الاوكراني بلسان ذلك الرجل الواثق من
مطالبه فطالب مجلس الامن تجريد روسيا من
حقها في النقد يجب ان تعطي الجمعيه العمل
للامم المتحده الفرصه لتجريد بعض الدول من
حق النقد انها خطوه ضروريه اذا لم يكن من
الممكن يوقف الحرب بسبب عرقله كل الجهود
من قبل الدوله المعتاديه او من قبل اولئك
الذين يدعون المعتدي فيجب عرض هذا الامر
على الجمعيه العامه للنظر فيه
لقاء زيلنسكي لم يمنعه من الرد عليه من
نفس المنبر مستندا على بند من ميثاق الامم
المتحده
ان استخدام حق النقد هو اداه مشروعه منصوص
عليها في ميثاق الامم المتحده لتجنب اتخاذ
قرارات يمكن ان تؤدي الى تقسيم المنظمه
اما وزير خارجيه الولايات المتحده انطوني
بلينكين فقد اكد على محتوى ما جاء على
لسان الرئيس الاوكراني واتهم روسيا
بارتكاب جرائم ضد الانسانيه
اولا الغزو الروسي في عزاته ينتهك الركيز
الاساسي لميثاق الامم المتحده احترام
سياده جميع الدول وسلامتها الاقليميه
ثانيا ترتكب روسيا جرائم حرب وجرائم ضد
الانسانيه في اوكرانيا بشكل يومي تقريبا
نفس المنحى ذهب اليه الامين العام للامم
المتحده
الذي انتقد بشده روسيا واتهمها بانتهاك
ميثاق الامم المتحده والقانون الدولي
بغزوها لاوكرانيا